but you keep not replying to them yeah
but you have to reply for me I don't
follow me yeah I can't do any of that
you're gonna do that sa question for I
literally don't listen anyone that knows
me knows that I don't know what happened
to me but over the years I just decided
not to know anything hmm
and not to have any kind of
responsibility yeah learned helplessness
what does that help listen what does
that mean it's when other people do
things for you you get you get trained
to not have to do them yourself right
and I think that's probably what I've
reinforced and it's a mistake on my part
because I do so much that he doesn't
think he has to ever lift a finger
literally I woke up today and she went
swimming no no one I just said it to
myself out loud until she gets back I
mean as soon as I come through the door
ah Hangul yeah and there's like I'm a
little baby like I'm waiting Briah
she goes what do you want I don't want
Jersey Mike's Jersey my yeah Mike's way
with you [ __ ] me today there's no potato
chips oh I ordered it that's not my
fault your post mates [ __ ] up no no I
think he deceived me but it's fine she
hid them thanks for the sandwich never
not even if you give him everything he
wants there's going to be at least one
or two complaints about yeah yeah yeah
know how to be satisfied it's not a part
of his DNA engineering yeah I like to
complain it's my favourite sport right
crazy it's better when we drive
I love complaining what is this guy
doing he's not doing anything he's just
stopping at a stoplight and he's yelling
behavior and so he yells that thinks he
has to yell at you he could not just sit
in place and be patient
yeah something has to be wrong the world
is against him it's what it is
let's be honest that's you know that's
when people stop when you die there's a
theory can I throw a theory beer away my
friend
throwing okay yes there'll be more
deaths but if I just listen to me listen
my logic there'd be more deaths and
accidents but if he everyone drove the
way I drove there be no such thing as
traffic how do you drive crazy like I
use sidewalk like he wants when I kill
me so no like he wants to kill all the
passes you know I just don't I don't
like I don't like for instance here's
the here's the thing you know how the in
LA there's a lot of left turns but
you're blocking a whole lane yeah yeah
it's one of those left two turns what
you don't have your own little pocket to
go into mmm I just don't take a left
because if I do I'm blocking that lane
he doesn't like to hold up traffic and
that is pretty nice of you
that's here's another thing I do and you
know I do this I run across the street
even in a crosswalk theme I do - yeah
you do - yeah because I hate it when
people walk I don't like it when people
take their [ __ ] time yeah so I
to be courteous I run across not because
of the traffic coming your way it's the
people trying to make a right yes
although I try to speed it up I speed it
up for and people don't have the same
courtesy toward me and it drives me
crazy but also if they're disabled Bobby
all the wheelchair faster if they have
like that one of those little hands a
little feet you know I mean that
underdeveloped then take your time yeah
I'll still scream but not as low just
quiet little things like this like it's
also like when you get on a plane right
I know exact second to get my [ __ ]
bag over the overhead compartment and my
bag underneath the seat and I'm sitting
down I know you're talking about I go
you know why done so no one can it has
to wait but then you got [ __ ] mister
like you know me long form I will be
like like takes his time I will oppose
you're not everyone is a frequent flyer
like you some people take trips like for
instance like my mom she's already a
nervous fly
she doesn't know she doesn't know the
drill the drill isn't engrained in her
memory so when she gets to the plane she
is sort of frazzled and she you know she
needs it she takes her you know she
needs more time than you thank you I
understand I understand that but one
time I came on a fly and this dude put
his backpack on to the aisle floor gun
on his knees and pulled out like
magazines a little thingy that he needed
and meanwhile there's work locked you
know and it's he and he's ruining
everyone's day
how do people not feel that like the
[ __ ] is oblivious to people are
oblivious and that's what I'm fighting
that in my life I have a similar fight
what I don't really have problems with
people in that sense like a in an
airplane I have problems with people who
hold up a food line that's but they hold
up a food line not just because they're
indecisive but they have a lot of for
instance if I were murdering something
but they have tents III truly think
these are the types of people who [ __ ]
it up for people with real food
allergies the LA people who pretend that
they have these gluten sensitivities and
who are allergic to ten different
different things and who hold up the
[ __ ] line because they don't know how
to read and therefore they ask the
person behind a counter can you tell me
what's in this what's in this what's in
this and then they have fifty different
requests that drives me crazy they [ __ ]
it up for people who have real allergies
because when those people with allergies
order food they get their eyes ruled out
because of all the other ones who
pretend to have [ __ ] allergies it
drives me crazy yeah I want to [ __ ]
just snatch him by the back of the head
man I feel like at times I feel rage I
have another one now this is you brought
that one up I hate it when there's a
group of five four or five two or three
it doesn't matter it's more than one
person and they're in a line and they
pay separately oh I see you're saying
yeah pull your money together order all
that ones cuz you're a group and get the
[ __ ] out of my life because they all
talk - no no what happens is like you
know I'll see a couple on a date
and the guy order him pay his and then
like the girls like ordering herself and
paying her own thing [ __ ] pay for her
even if he is she's just you know a
friend at work do you think you think so
yeah I don't think that man have I was
like that I was like that when I had no
money that's my number one out yeah but
I I go out with male friends and
sometimes I get the bill sometimes they
do it's and sometimes we split the bill
I know but still in a line at least
McDonald's I'm not saying like at a
restaurant I'm just saying at life's a
Domino's right that's like five bucks
pay for the other person yeah if you
have it just stop being difficult stop
being you know just think about it I'm
in line the back of you need my rage
[Music]